good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's time
for an unboxing video so as previously
noted if you open up any of these boxes
you'll find you know yet another box but
it is not boxes all the way down because
if you open up this box what you'll find
is paper lots of paper like that
particular box contains two thousand
sheets and I am signing those sheets of
paper one at a time
over and over again I've been doing it
off and on for about six months actually
it's been a little bit hard to keep this
all a secret but when I announced last
week that I finally have a new book
coming out Turtles all the way down
coming out October 10th lots of people
were like are you gonna sign all the
pre-orders will all the pre-orders be
signed no I want to be very clear about
that in fact there is a website we'll
all pre-orders of turtles all the way
down be signed com know so the only way
to sign all the pre-orders for a book is
to sign the entire first printing for
The Fault in Our Stars that was a
hundred fifty thousand copies some of
you might remember this which Sara made
for me in 2011 to help me you know chart
my path to 150,000 signatures because I
did sign almost all of the pre-orders
for that book but Turtles all the way
down is gonna have a first printing of
like 1.5 million copies and it's just
not possible to sign that many books I
looked into it maybe somebody could do
it but not me however I am going to sign
200,000 copies of the book hopefully
slightly more but at least 200,000 again
just to emphasize this does not mean
that all pre-orders of turtles all the
way down will be signed because they
won't for one thing this is only going
to work in the US and Canada I'm really
sorry if you live outside the US in
Canada but on the upside by not being
American you probably get universal
health care so maybe that's even worth
more than an autograph
okay so in the book world there are
these things called ISBN numbers every
book has one they used to be ten digit
numbers now there are 13 digits and for
many years a large percentage of my job
was typing ISBN numbers into a database
so as it happens I know a lot about ISBN
numbers for instance each publisher has
its own particular ISBN prefix 0-0 six
is HarperCollins 0-3 one six is little
brown one - two - four is the University
of Chicago Press I could go on but you'd
get bored in fact my first thought when
I found out Looking for Alaska was gonna
be published by Dutton was I'm gonna be
a zero - five - five - incidentally I'm
very proud all these years later to
still be published by Dutton and still
be a zero - five - five - but I am on a
tangent right so Turtles all the way
down has to ISBN numbers and
one of those ISBN numbers is for signed
books everyone's gonna have some signed
copies your local bookstore will have
some target will have some amazon will
have some etc and you will have the
highest chance although still not a
guarantee of getting a signed book if
you order that ISBN number there are
many links in the dooblydoo to buy the
book with that ISBN number from all over
the place but let me just quickly say
that if I were you I would order the
book from my local bookstore so yeah
that is the ISBN for the signed edition
it doesn't cost any more than the
regular edition it's just more likely to
have a signature also Sara took this
from 2011 and made me this for 2017 it's
a thermometer resting on the back of a
turtle that is itself resting on the
back of another turtle presumably ad
infinitum as you can see here since
January working when I had extra time I
have reached 80 thousand books and then
I have like about two months to just get
there by the way if you're wondering
what 80,000 sheets of paper looks like
this is 38 fidget spinner for scale and
there's another 40 mm most of the pages
are just signed but about three percent
have a dftba on them then there's also a
bunch of them that I've yetis drawn by
Sarah there's also a few that Alice has
circled in hot pink and there are
several hundred that Henry has drawn
pokeballs on it's kind of a family
affair this signing thing so Inc that's
the news I have a new book coming out
it's called Turtles all the way down I
am so excited and also so relieved I am
going to sign 200,000 copies are
hopefully slightly more and if you live
in the US or Canada you can preorder a
signed copy at your local book store or
via the links in the doobly-doo Hank I
got to get to signing I'll see you on
Friday
PS one more thing I need your help
deciding which Sharpie colors to use
there is a survey in the doobly-doo
thank you bye